schwimmen behindern können geboren und
groß geworden habe es mir jetzt auch
egal wer den kopf schüttelt oder wäre
das witzig finde ich kenne alle familien
und es hat noch nie ein klein gesehen
wir versuchen jetzt irgendwas
einzubinden es gibt klar sind besser
aufpassen
alles bullshit es stimmt alles was also
dass das ist falsch aber total falsch 13
fragen hier kommt die erste was glaubt
ihr befeuern polizei und medien in
sachen sogenannter kleinkriminalität
rassistische vorurteile wenn ihr sagt er
ja da werden ja ganze großfamilien
stigmatisiert dann bitte auf dem grünen
feld positionieren wenn ihr sagt er nein
da geht es weniger um rassismus als um
eine unterschätzte gefahr dann bitte auf
dem gelben feld positionieren bitteschön
[Musik]
jetzt wissen wir ungefähr wo ihr steht
jetzt legen wir los bushido prozess und
abou chaker dazu drogensumpf und
polizeirazzien außerdem etliche tv dokus
zum thema und natürlich die serie 4
blocks die sogenannte klaren
kriminalität ist mindestens mal ein
medialer dauerbrenner
dabei wird so der vorwurf nicht nur jagd
auf kriminelle gemacht sondern
möglicherweise auf alle die
zufälligerweise den falschen nachnamen
haben sippenhaft ist also unser bild der
so genannten arabischen clans nur
aufgebauscht oder handelt es sich im
gegenteil um eine völlig unterschätzte
gefahr was glaubt ihr
auf welcher seite dieses feldes hättet
ihr euch jetzt positioniert auf gelb
oder grün
bin gespannt auf eure kommentare
für euch liebe gäste heißt es ab sofort
wie immer wenn ihr einem argument der
gegenseite zustimmt dann könnt ihr gerne
einen schritt auf sie zugehen nach vorne
oder wenn ihr sagt dass totaler bullshit
was die da gerade erzählen dann geht ja
gerne einen schritt zurück das ziel
dieses format und natürlich auch mein
ziel ist es möglichst viele von euch am
ende hier in diesem kompromiss feld zu
versammeln
das hat schon diverse male gut geklappt
ich bin sehr gespannt bis heute so wird
in diesem sinne 13 fragen hier kommt
frage nummer zwei und die geht an alle
du bist ja nicht nur ein besonders
erfolgreicher rapper du bist ja auch der
cousin von besagtem arafat abou chaker
der wiederum gilt als clan boss oder
zumindest als zentrale figur in der
berliner unterwelt bist du also nicht
nur teil einer familie sondern auch teil
eines kriminellen clans
ich bin teil einer familie aber ich bin
keiner instanz
was machst du was sagst du zu leuten die
sagen du hast du auch dazu ja das ist
halt wie du schon gesagt hast du anfangs
hat irgendwas bisschen was von
sippenhaft so es ist für mich nicht
einfach redet jedes mal damit in
verbindung gebracht zu werden das
bedeutet egal was ich mache mein leben
wird immer wieder danach gesagt du bist
ja klar mit dieter hast du nicht gesehen
mittlerweise nämlich jetzt nicht mehr
für voll was soll ich denn machen sollte
ich wohl nicht fall gefragt in welcher
familie region werden möchte und es ist
so wie mit
wie soll ich die vergleich zum beispiel
du bist du jemandem befreundet oder
müssen wir jemanden cool und so dann
irgendwann kommt der streifen kommt
immer derselbe spruch sogar ein essay
von der seiner kleinen familie und so
kann ich gar nicht mehr ernst nehmen ich
finde das thema ist ein bisschen
der letzten jahre ein bisschen zu heiß
gekocht wurden als die kleine schreit
ist schon heute klar qualität und das
finde ich einfach ein bisschen
lächerlich
euro was sagst du du bist der polizistin
hast viele auch mit dem milieu in
anführungszeichen zu tun kannst du das
nachvollziehen wird es zum schritt auf
ihn zugehen
ich finds halt schwierig insofern als
dass er ja auch als aus
kriminalpolizeilicher sicht eben wissen
dass diese familienstrukturen eben sehr
verwoben sind
na also man kann das halt nicht so ganz
trennen ich verstehe aber auch es gibt
ja auch teile von diesen familien die
sich eben dadurch davon abgrenzen und
eben sagen nein ich habe eben nichts mit
diesen kriminellen machenschaften zu tun
ja ich könnte mich davon ab
kleinkriminalität ist meiner meinung
nach gefährlich weil es das subjektive
sicherheitsgefühl der bevölkerung
deutlich beeinflusst es hat nie
behauptet dass es sowas gibt also
kriminelle machenschaften
ich kenne meine gibt es ganz meiner
familie diese gruppe wird immer heißer
gekocht als gegessen wird wenn es jetzt
hier nur meine also familie geht habe
ich doch also gar kein bock mehr als sie
mit zum auf ein spezialist es geht ja
eben nicht nur um dein tragen wir können
es nur darum gibt jenny und eine
spezielle familie geht sowieso gar nicht
das ist der super also ich würde ich
würde den schritt auf ihn zugehen wenn
ich mir vorstelle dass ich jetzt hier
stehen würde und in dieser art und weise
über meine familie gesprochen die haben
da würde dann löst das natürlich auch
eine emotionalität aus und ich finde das
beispiel von ali gomaa je zeigt
eigentlich wie gefährlich es ist wenn
wir alles unter generalverdacht stellen
und wie schwierig es ist auch mit dem
thema klaren strukturen fair und gerecht
umzugehen
und trotzdem finde ich es wichtig dass
wir nicht die erste frage stellen dass
rassismus auf das sozusagen rassistisch
ist wenn man das benennt es geht ja
darum dass von den menschen von denen
verbrechen begangen werden dass die
dafür auch die konsequenzen in kauf
nehmen müssen unabhängig davon ob sie
alle heißen ahmed heißen michael oder
melanie das ist sozusagen der ansatz
aber wenn einer dabei ist der sozusagen
unschuldig ist und auch in der
generalverdacht gebracht wird dann haben
auch wir als gesellschaft versagt und
genau das finde ich ist die
herausforderung und ich finde das kommt
eigentlich ganz deutlich zum ausdruck
das heißt du kann darf es gerne auf ihn
zugehen in dem fall
und trotzdem muss man natürlich sagen
die das bka hat ja sogar eine definition
die sagen klar der besteht laut polizei
aus angehörigen ethnisch abgeschotteter
subkulturen also es gibt ja offenbar
doro dann doch irgendwie eine kategorie
auch wenn die irgendwie sehr schwammig
daher kommt ja also das problem meiner
meinung nach hat die politik das so ein
bisschen verschlafen sozusagen früh
genug anzugehen
deswegen gibt es diese ethnisch
abgeschotteten zu kulturen na also
wenn man sich jetzt mal anguckt wie war
das von vor drei generationen zum
beispiel ja da haben wir es sind
flüchtlingsfamilien beispielsweise
gekommen die eben aus ihrem land
geflüchtet sind aus diversen gründen und
kommen dann halt in ein land wo sie
damals noch nicht arbeiten durften und
so weiter und so fort und wie gehen sie
damit um aber mohammed glaubst du denn
dass wir jetzt aktuell bei solchen
definitionen die sie gerade vorgelesen
habe den richtigen weg gehen
also wenn man es überhaupt definition
nennen kann also schwammig ist glaube
ich auch sehr diplomatisch ausgedrückt
ich habe mich jetzt jahrelang damit
auseinandergesetzt und auch kritisch auf
die polizeiarbeit in verschiedensten
bundesländern geguckt und da ist sehr
viel falsch gelaufen
vielleicht ist aber auch noch mal
wichtig beim thema clanstrukturen
das ist ja kein kavaliersdelikt
kleinkriminalität ist für mich deswegen
ein problem weil es opfer generiert das
sind keine bagatelldelikte es geht um
sexuelle ausbeutung es geht um
prostitution
es geht um organisierte kriminalität und
meistens kommen die opfer selber aus den
milieus und deswegen müssen wir darüber
reden
die tatsache dass viel schiefgelaufen
ist als die menschen bekommen sind vor
über dreißig vierzig jahren dass es die
residenzpflicht gab dass man nicht
arbeiten durfte ich habe viel mit diesen
jungs auch in neukölln viel zeit
verbracht als redakteurin hat mit ihnen
gedreht und da war keiner dabei der
keine träume hatte oder der nicht
partizipieren wollte an der gesellschaft
aber es war de facto so dass hier nicht
arbeiten durften aber nochmal ich glaube
die verantwortung liegt bei den menschen
immer noch die diese verbrechen begehen
und das sind auch diejenigen die diesen
nachnamen in mitleidenschaft ziehen
mir tun die familienmitglieder leid die
damit nichts zu tun haben aber kollektiv
mit in haftung genommen werden
aber der generalverdacht den der kommt
ja nicht der kommt ja nicht von den
familien der kommt ja von der
gesellschaft die da drauf schaut
also irgendwie scheint ja der umgang
zumindest laut mohammed der falsche zu
soll aber das muss ich auch über
berichten gerne und darüber berichten
ist ganz wichtig da können wir auch
nochmal medienkritik machen einige
kollegen kollegen lassen sich einfach
dinge erzählen wir sind die harten wir
gehen durch neukölln vor blogs gucken
und dann noch mal in die reportagereihe
kippen und es kommt tatsächlich
kriminellen menschen zugute weil die auf
dieses harte image aufbauen
beim thema so genannte klangqualität mit
der ich mich auch als investigativer
journalist auseinandergesetzt habe da
kann ich sagen ich bin kein kriminologe
weiß aber dass polizeiarbeit die nach
rassistischen mustern funktioniert nicht
im sinne unserer sicherheit ist und mehr
schaden anrichtet als dass sie dinge
aufklärt wenn wir sagen in berlin gibt
es zum beispiel 1000 fälle pro jahr
ein sogenannter kleinkriminalität wenn
man sich die statistiken anschaut und
das haben sehr wenige kollegen kollegen
in der vergangenheit gemacht dann findet
man tatsächlich drogen kriminalität oder
zwangsprostitution
neben zu schnell gefahren auf der
autobahn oder zu langsam gefahren auf
der autobahn und dann kann man sich
irgendwie da auch noch mal die
dimensionen des problems anschauen wenn
sich ein innenminister hinstellt egal in
welchem bundesland und sagt ich habe
diese kriminalität und ganz viele
kollegen kollegen bei der pk nicht
kritisch nachfragen läuft auch aus
medialer sicht etwas falsch da können
wir auch mal bei dieser frage ja du bist
ja strafverteidigerin und du hast viel
mit dem thema zu tun hat man mit dem
falschen nachnamen schwierigkeiten sagen
wir mal vor gericht
also wenn man vor gericht ist dann hat
man ein problem auf alle fälle egal mit
welchem nach nahm ich meine dass ein
großes problem daran besteht dass die
medien so tun als sei das die
kriminalität an sich sowohl in
quantitativer als qualitativer hinsicht
und das stimmt einfach nicht das ist ein
bereich von vielen der absolut
überbewertet wird
was ich berichten kann ist auf alle
fälle im nachgang also beim vollzug von
gefängnisstrafen und so weiter auch
probleme der drei die viel weniger
chancen bekommen als andere und da gerne
anders behandelt werden sollen als
andere und der normale mensch der der
normale inhaftierte der sich da eben
nicht diesen vorurteilen ausgesetzt
sieht was heißt anders behandelt werden
zur frage von den chancen gegeben werden
sich in sogenannten lockerungen zu
bewähren und all das da wird dann eben
gerne aus sicht der staatsanwaltschaft
die denjenigen dann oka vermerk
ausdrücken ohne dass das gericht das
also noka vermerk heißt dass gesagt wird
derjenige der organisierten kriminalität
zugehörig obwohl das strafgericht das
gerade nicht festgestellt hat die sind
dann einfach mehr belastet und ebenfalls
wirklichen fortkommen gehindert greift
fast antwortet darauf also die sache mit
dem general gedacht ist ein problem für
viele aber nicht für alle ich finde es
wichtig über diese problematik zu
berichten weil ich gesehen habe wie
diese problematik immer größer wurde und
die sehr eng mit der migrations
verbunden und man hat sie jahrzehntelang
einfach übersehen
bei manchem familie wenn ich ein
geschäft habe und jemand bei mir
arbeiten will dann werde ich mir richtig
überlegen ob ich das tue weil ich weiß
wenn bei dem kleine konflikte habe ich
die ganze sippe vor dem laden und ich
kann nicht mehr raus und das ist der
unterschied zwischen dieser
kleinkriminalität und der organisierte
kriminalität
sie beruht auf verwandtschaft kannst du
das nachvollziehen was er sagt hast du
das schon mal erlebt selber ja wenn mein
kleiner bruder problem hat com ist also
dass wenn ich da wenn ich dafür plant
und dann bin ich keiner bin ich kann gut
du setzt dich so nennt es aber familien
solidarität als ein prozent sogar
kleiner bruder kann es kurz zu sagen ich
hab's nicht vergessen wie bewertet ihr
das was er gerade gesagt habe
also ich finde diese haltung die man
allenfalls für psychologen interessant
sein ist es einfach schwachsinn finde
ich aber ganz ehrlich wieso es ist
einfach schwachsinn
sich darüber aufzuregen dass menschen
zueinander halten ja und erst recht wenn
sie familie verbunden sind ja in jedem
anderen kontext würde man das erwarten
voneinander und wird das gepredigt und
gelebt ja oder vermisst wenn es ja nicht
mehr so ist das wäre bei deutschen
familien doch genauso ja und zu sagen
wenn wenn es einen konflikt gibt ein
konflikt ist noch keine straftat ja und
daraus ist kann man auch nicht herleiten
dass wenn es ein problem gibt und ein
großer bruder sich für einen kleinen
bruder einsetzt dass damit eine straftat
einhergeht und es ist vor allem
schwachsinn zu behaupten dass
kleinkriminalität also dass die
straftaten miteinander begehen müssen
weil sie miteinander verwandt sind aber
im berichtete von
einschüchterungsversuchen das heißt
möglicherweise von nötigung
das hast du ja gemeint also das hat
davon berichtet er dass es kommt noch
schlimmer
also der will habe ein paralleles die
versuchen ihre probleme untereinander zu
lösen
ich bin ein beispiel ich würde doch
bedruckt und stand unter personenschutz
es gibt zwei wege entweder halte ich
mich an dem re-start und verhalte mich
wie ich gemacht habe mit allen
nachteilen
oder ich habe kontakte in der gruppe ich
kenne viele leute die 16 jahre lang habe
ich mit denen gearbeitet und die alte
generation war in meinem büro in der
beratungsstelle die alte ehe der weg von
denen faire dass ich jemanden
einschalten dann gibt es ein treffen mit
denen ich entschuldige mich
wir müssen uns und die sache ist
erledigt verstehen sie da stand ich vor
gewalt ich glaube wir dürfen das auch
nicht miteinander jetzt also ist es
wichtig dass man ja auch gerade ich
komme selber aus einem kulturkreis der
kollektivistisch geprägt ist und das ist
ein ganz großer unterschied zu der
individualisierten gesellschaft ich habe
zehn geschwister wir sind ehrlich kinder
zu hause ich habe eine große familie
das heißt wenn wir dieses thema
ansprechen beispielsweise auch das
der rassistisch gelesenen menschen die
benachteiligt werden und das einfach
fakt lasst uns in sachen benennen wie
sie sind wenn du in den falschen
nachnamen hast kriegst du keine wohnung
und christ auch nicht den richtigen job
und da muss noch nicht mal auf schalke
heißen mit nachnamen
das heißt das ist schon mal klar dass da
eine benachteiligung ist bei menschen
mit sichtbarer migrationsgeschichte
wenn da noch der kriminalitäts aspekt
dazu kommt dann ist das natürlich noch
mal eine andere komponente
und dann finde ich jetzt falsch dass nur
rassistisch zu lesen
das heißt ist es ganz wichtig glaube ich
auch für die aufnehmende gesellschaft
auch für deutschland als
einwanderungsgesellschaft im zeitalter
der pluralisierung zu verstehen was da
passiert und zu überlegen was wir alle
daran also sozusagen ansetzen können und
tun können damit der nachname abou
chaker in 20 jahren nicht mehr mit
kriminalität in verbindung gebracht wird
was meint ihr
besteht ein generalverdacht wenn du den
falschen nachnamen hast vielleicht habt
ihr ja sogar den falschen nachnamen was
sind eure erfahrungen fragen wir doch
mal die polizisten wir haben ja eine
dagegen bei bestimmten familien nahmen
die alarmglocken an
auf dem revier sagt man dann ist müssen
wir aber nicht mit zu 22 kollegen hin
fahren sondern wir nehmen lieber mal wir
sind ja alle nicht vorurteilsfrei ja
also wir haben ja alle vorurteile
es ist eben nur wichtig dass wir uns
eben auch insbesondere als polizei immer
wieder ins gedächtnis rufen und zu sagen
ja wir haben vorurteile und wir müssen
aber damit umgehen wir müssen versuchen
so weit wie möglich das ganze trotzdem
objektiv zu sehen ja ich bin ja auch nur
ein mensch ich bin kein roboter und ich
würde sagen ja es gehen alarmglocken an
weil man eben bestimmte erfahrungen
vielleicht schon gemacht hat und davon
bin ich nicht frei also auch als
polizisten nicht weil meine alarmglocken
angehen wenn die tür mit hamburg
angetreten wird und mit springerstiefeln
auf den kopf getreten obwohl sich das
einer wohnung in der gemeinde
alarmglocken
er ist jetzt angesagt nicht mehr
schlafen kann wenn man irgendwas im haus
gehört und wenn man dann hört wir haben
uns eine tür vater sagt meine war
dagegen ein alarmglocken wisst ihr das
passiert erst passiert zweimal so genau
das darauf zielt eine frage bei der
sogenannten stand kriminalität gibt es
ja die die politik der tausend
nadelstiche sagt man
und genau da wird über die
verhältnismäßigkeit gesprochen
so muss man mit einer hundertschaft
einen später zum beispiel kontrollieren
geben dass ich übertreibe jetzt ein
bisschen was würdet ihr dann vorschlagen
was was wäre denn verhältnismäßig
wirklich evidenzbasiert einfach
kriminalität bekämpfen
es kann ja nicht sein dass der
bezirksbürgermeister von neukölln
zusammen mit der polizei und einigen
kolleginnen kollegen sie absprechen um
etwas zu inszenieren
ich habe das auch noch mal nach rangiert
in der sonnenallee große stammt haben
viel polizei
immer wenn ich nach frage danach was
wurde eigentlich gefunden entweder ein
paar kilo unversteuerten shisha tabak
und ich bin nicht dafür dass die
sicherheit nicht verstrahlt wird oder so
und das war es und es geht nicht aber
dann ist das kind schon in den brunnen
gefallen weil in der boulevardpresse in
öffentlich rechtlichen medien auch oder
auch in privatsendern schon diese bilder
quasi gesendet worden sind und da würde
ich mir wünschen dass weniger auf
inszenierung und mehr auf faktenbasierte
polizeiarbeit und berichterstellung
gesetzt wird wenn man dem das erste
lagebild der polizei über
kleinkriminalität von letzter woche
sieht dann sind die straßen die masse
der straftaten ziemlich beachtlich
also das ist kein bagatelldelikt und das
ist nicht aus bosheit und antirassismus
rassismus dass die polizei so was mache
ich kenne die arbeit der polizei
ich weiß welche anstrengungen sie macht
und welche ergebnisse sie ja man braucht
nur ihre berichte zu sehen und zu merken
wie ausgewogen wie vorsichtig und wie
sie an der sache ganz ganz nah dran
gehen
genau um diese vorwurf von rassismus
entgegenzukommen
aber überzeugt dass rea was er gerade
sagt weil es gibt ja offenbar kriminelle
strukturen die man angehen will
ja also ist überzeugt mich nicht
ich will das nicht klein reden natürlich
gibt es straftaten in dem bereich und
von diesen leuten begangen aber was mich
ganz erheblich stört ist dass da sehr
unter die linse geschaut wird und ein
sehr enger tunnelblick vorgenommen wird
und sich überhaupt nicht damit
auseinandergesetzt wird was kriminalität
ist wer kriminalität begeht kriminalität
ist immer auch ein mangel an
möglichkeiten und wie sich das
entwickelt und man muss dann für
größeren auch in zeitlich größeren blick
nehmen aber das will ich jetzt
gefährlich was sie sagen weil ich finde
dass wir das jetzt damit relativieren
das ist ja das totschlag argument zu
sagen es gab keinen anderen ausweg und
deswegen musste jemand in die
kriminalität abrutschen also ich glaube
sie sollten auch auf die
entscheidungsfähigkeit des individuums
setzen ja und das ist wohl überlegt hast
ja also dass wer auch immer ein renner
können ja auch einen anderen namen ins
spiel bringen dann die anderen remus
belastet wenn er sich selbst strafbar
macht also ich habe noch kein strafrecht
das habe ich nicht behauptet liegst du
bist was folgt dass sie die
verantwortung für ihre eigenen
straftaten georgen und damit auch
verantwortlich sind wenn dann andere
muss sie keine begehen aber nur vier
stellen wie hat man das wenn sie ja aber
sagt eingegeben würden dann sind sie
doch selber dafür verantwortlich oder
wollen sie durch eigenverantwortlich
aber ist diskreditiert damit nicht tun
sie das auto motto der strafrichter auf
der welt als strafzumessung sgr und
gesagt also da gibt es noch mal sechs
monate extra für das du dir dafür sorgt
dass ich jetzt mein leben lang alle
müllers doof finde also das hat man
gesehen dass vergleichen weil ich dieses
konstrukt über der familie müller nicht
gibt ich kenne es nicht ich persönlich
kenne ich aber die ennahda wenn dem so
wäre dann gilt das selbe natürlich auch
zur familie müller genauso wie für die
italienische mafia
das hat also deswegen das ist für mich
sozusagen das keine moralisieren und es
hat nicht
frage der herkunft es ist eine frage der
verbrechen die begangen werden oder eben
nicht halte ich mich an diesen
rechtsstaat oder tue ich das nicht und
es mir wirklich egal wo derjenige
herkommt kannst du damit gehen dass
natürlich die schuldigen auch in fotos
den etat ist für das verantwortlich was
er gemacht hat olaf rechtlich ist er
dafür zur verantwortung zu ziehen oder
muss dann muss mit den konsequenzen
leben
aber er kriegt keine verantwortung für
wen auch immer wie der dann behandelt
wird von der gesellschaft die
gesellschaft trägt die verantwortung
dafür wie wir andere behandeln genauso
habe ich das ja auch gesagt dass
derjenige für sich selber verantwortlich
ist aber wenn die gesellschaft dann
beispielsweise den sohn oder den bruder
anders liest und haben wir ja sozusagen
das zusatz problem und dafür möchten wir
natürlich die ganze gesellschaft mit in
sich an der einzelne straftäter nicht
verantwortlich wir haben diesen
tunnelblick weil wir nun mal nur mit
diesen leuten konfrontiert werden die da
in verdacht geraten
aber wir sehen all die anderen ramos
apothekers als sein sonst wenig team
ganz normales leben führen die
vielleicht nur zwei geschwister zwei
kinder haben oder auch 10 und sich
keiner von den strafbar macht und von
denen gibt es ganz ganz viele
und die müssen wir noch mehr sichtbar
machen und sehen aber nicht mehr ganz
bei dir ja es dazu würde ich eben auch
gerne noch mal was sagen nun ist es aber
so dass ja auch struktur ermittlungen
ergeben haben dass gelder zum beispiel
die durch die großfamilie erwirtschaftet
werden eben auch als unterstützung auch
in diese familien teile trotzdem mit
rhein fließen ja ob sie nun mal was darf
damit zu tun haben wollen oder nicht ob
sie selber straftaten begehen oder nicht
nur das ist mit sicherheit kein
arabisches phänomen nicht und
deutschland ist geldwäsche land nummer
eins er seit jahrzehnten vielfach
abgemahnt vom von von der europäischen
union dafür und von allen anderen ohne
dass das irgendetwas mit irgend einmal
aber zu tun hätte aber der punkt den die
sender jetzt mehrfach
vor geholt hat nämlich dass die
kriminellen auch mit dafür
verantwortlich sind dass die die
familienmitglieder und in
mitleidenschaft gezogen werden
da könnte man ja auf der andern seite
fragen müssten sich nicht die ganzen
recht schaffenden familienmitgliedern
noch stärker vielleicht sogar öffentlich
noch mehr distanz er wird dass wir hier
schon so tun als die übrigen gerade so
nach dem motto wir haben klar und diesen
safe wir sind sicher war und jetzt reden
wir über die opfer der clans ich bin
bilden der können geboren und groß
geworden
ich weiß jetzt auch egal wer ist im kopf
schüttelt oder werde das witzig findet
ich kenne alle familien und ich habe
noch nie einen kleinen gesehen dass es
leute gibt die scheiße bauen kann sein
was heißt das ist doch alles gute
familie nicht kennen wir alle ja wir
sind es gibt gute leute das geschlecht
ich hab nachbar diesen scheiß es gibt
diesen gut aber ich habe noch nie in
meinem leben einen klar etwas was wir
klar das ist immer jemanden gibt der
scheiße man kann ja wirklich passieren
auch meiner familie geworden würde ich
nicht nein aber er hat doch war auch für
diese klaren vision also sagst es gibt
gar keine organisierten fans nicht gibt
s nicht keiner auch endlich sind mein
cousin ich habe 150 längst vielleicht in
berlin
wenn ich jetzt meine alte auf der straße
laufe und werden angegriffen und
verprügelt gesagt ist dann gemeldet kein
vater sagst du deinen sohn gehen wir
jetzt raus und mach mal so und so was
gibt's gar nicht
egal welche familie gerade genannt
worden ist ich kennen wir alle viele von
denen das war alles gute menschen und
der ganzen humbug der versuchen
erzählungen was einzureden irgendwelche
stimme in den köpfen der duh zu
versuchen es gibt klar so müssen alle
aufpassen
alles bullshit es stimmt bleibt mache ja
also dass das ist falsch
aber total falsch der beweise
ich beziehe mich und als ich mein buch
geschrieben haben auf die berichte der
polizei und die polizei
das ist eine antwort auf was sie gesagt
haben auch die geht ganz vorsichtig
damit und also die haben ganz empirisch
angefangen ich rede in die haben
festgestellt dass bei jeder aktion die
treten immer als bande jeder aktion
da sind immer dieselben leute und dann
habe sie geschickt und da haben sie
gefunden oder sind ihre verwandtschaft
also die sind nicht von den namen her
gehe ausgegangen sondern von den taten
und dann habe sie festgestellt es gibt
hier eine art organisation die auf die
verwandtschaft beruht so ist der begriff
kleinkriminalität entstanden mohammed
ist ja nun journalist und der
neutralität verpflichtet du hast ja dann
auch sehr viel in dem thema recherchiert
was glaubst du gibt es kriminelle
organisierte strukturen ja oder nein
natürlich gibt es kriminelle
organisierte strukturen die heißen
wirecard zb die heißen aber auch keine
ahnung bestimmt diese diskussion gerade
da ging es um dimension des problems und
ich will gerne an einigen beispielen
nochmal das kritisch diskutieren
sagen wir mal dieses kleine feld hier
ist niedersachsen und das hier ist
bremen in bremen hat irgendwann mal
gemerkt
diese rassistische art und weise des
zufrieden das funktioniert nicht das war
vor fünf sechs sieben jahren
deswegen haben sie die methodik ihrer
statistik geändert das hat dazu geführt
dass ich in bremen total sicher bin
da gibt es ein bisschen
kleinkriminalität aber ist alles okay
meine mutter würde sagen bremen kannst
du leben kein problem statistik alles
super wenn ich über die grenze gehen
nach niedersachsen
um gottes willen aber überall alles in
flammen und das meine ich mit
statistiken auch kritisch lesen und die
muss man wirklich kritisch lesen weil
was von staatlicher seite aufgetischt
wird das ist meine aufgabe als
journalist das noch mal zu
dekonstruieren
sein credo ist und total angekommen für
mehr differenzierung auch gerade bei
statistiken polizeistatistiken aber wir
haben offenbar das ist oft eine
schwierigkeit bei diesem thema überhaupt
eine definition zu finden und trotzdem
müssen wir mal fragen wenn wenn wenn wir
alle sagt es gibt keine clowns haben wir
dann kein problem
aus meiner sicht haben wir bundesweiten
problem dass jedes bundesland für sich
so ein bisschen kleinkriminalität
definiert und eben sagt ja dass das hier
ist ein plan bei clans verbindet man
sofort ja nicht die deutschen sondern
die araber so ist es halt das ist
gesellschaftlich einfach so es seit dem
begriff mit dem
mittlerweile so ein bisschen was
anfangen kann wobei die geflechte der
sogenannten araber deutsche sind oder
viel haut zeigen
das ist deutsche dagegen sie die araber
clans kindergeburtstag ist es geht ja
darum unabhängig davon wo man herkommt
das gilt natürlich auch für die andere
seite also wenn wenn wir wie dieser tage
mit korruptionsvorwürfen konfrontiert
sind
die haben nichts mit arabischen großes
zutun und da möchte ich jetzt auch nicht
relativieren
aber da wird ja auch wenn ja auch
gesetze gebrochen da wird ja auch
vertrauen missbraucht und ich glaube es
ist ganz ganz wichtig dass auch alles im
blick zu haben
auch news angesprochen hast und sich
nicht immer nur auf einen tunnelblick zu
konzentrieren und diese an contis bei
ist also diese vorteile die wir alle
selber haben auch immer wieder zu
hinterfragen und natürlich macht es dann
auch sind über solche begrifflichkeiten
zu diskutieren denn noch mal wenn jetzt
daraus abgeleitet wird das jeder
arabische großfamilie kriminelle ist
dann ist das hochgefährlich und
entspricht auch nicht der realität ja
und auf der anderen seite glaube ich
eben schon dass die skandia glaube ich
einen halben schritt ja auch tatsächlich
wochen ich mich an die spielregeln 1 a
warum bist du mein pony bin ja weil du
sachen gesagt dass die ich okay finde
also dass wir natürlich alles im blick
nehmen müssen und es nicht sein kann
dass wir jetzt ableiten
alle arabischen familien seien kriminell
viele schritte seid ihr noch nicht
gelaufen ist überrascht mich bei dieser
art der diskussion nicht unbedingt bei
diesem thema vor allem dann ist auch
wirklich ein bisschen defizit aber
zumindest ria bist du wieder nachhinein
ist so halb nach vorne und du stehst
diese ausschauen wie du gehst ja immer
noch weiter vor ich bin auf den es sein
müsste passieren damit und schritt vor
gehst du zu sagen jetzt also damit damit
schon sachen gesagt die ich fühle so
klar aber ich weiß dass wir alles so ein
bisschen so weiß ich nicht ich glaube
wenn man keine so schöne worte hat
sollte man wissen mal im unterhalten du
hast uns doch schon mit sehr schönen
worten beglückt heute aber das war's
also ich kann vielleicht kann ich ja was
zu sagen er bitte ali ist auf jeden fall
auch ein vorbild für viele kids da
draußen gerade auch durch seine
vermittelnde art seine verbinden derart
durch seine social media
auftritte und ich glaube es ist ganz
wichtig ist sich genau darauf zu
konzentrieren also auch wie wir
sozusagen werteorientierte
präventionsmaßnahmen bildungsmaßnahmen
möglichkeiten im parlament schaffen
können und ich glaube wir brauchen auch
role models aus ganz unterschiedlichen
bereichen dies de facto nicht gibt aber
ich glaube wir müssen uns noch viel mehr
auf die verantwortungsbereiche
gesellschaft von morgen konzentrieren
und das muss auch die politik verstehen
dass das im eigenen interesse sein muss
wenn jeder dritte migrationshintergrund
hat in zukunft also die frage ist nicht
nur was ist ein arabischer groß klein
sondern was ist deutsch und dass wir
letztlich auch alle teil dieser
gesellschaft sein müssen egal wie der
aussehen und wo wir herkommen wenn wir
das wollen wenn wir das wollen und die
ärmel hochkrempeln müssen wir aber auch
die möglichkeiten dafür bekommen so ist
frage an euch ist was haltet ihr von dem
plan begriff wir haben hier diskutiert
gibt es eine definition die euch
zufriedenstellt oder ist das totaler
schwachsinn diesen begriff überhaupt zu
verwenden wenn wir ihn nicht verwenden
wie können wir das problem so wie es
ralf angesagt hat wie können wir das
problem trotzdem angehen denn es gibt ja
offensichtlich ein problem mit
organisierter kriminalität also was sind
die begriffe was habt ihr für
erfahrungen beziehungsweise was habt ihr
übrigens bis jetzt aus dieser diskussion
gelernt schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare ich weiß es nicht einfach
aber wir versuchen natürlich trotzdem
irgendwie aufeinander zu zu kommen und
das wollen wir jetzt auch tun wir wollen
so eine art kompromiss runde ist jetzt
ein bisschen schwierig dafür sind wir
noch ein bisschen weit voneinander
entfernt vielleicht aber vielleicht
können wir uns ja auch gewisse thesen
einigen ich war mal mit einem mann mit
der frage der kommunikation
ich glaube da sind wir uns ziemlich
eigentlich gewesen also wenn wir davon
ausgehen dass die mediale
berichterstattung über so genannte
arabische clans verzerrt die realität
darstellt in sachen organisierter
kriminalität insgesamt
da muss man sagen man hat den eindruck
die sogenannte kleinkriminalität ist
riesengroß du hast mehrfach gesagt so
groß ist das gar nicht manchmal wird es
auch größer gemacht durch statistiken
zudem werden bisweilen auch nicht immer
rassistische klischees befeuert da sind
wir uns glaube ich in dieser runde auch
einig gewesen
also ich sag mal der minimal kompromiss
wäre jetzt meine frage 11 wir treten
deshalb ein wir alle hier für eine
erhöhte sensibilität in der
kommunikation sowohl bei polizei medien
als auch bei uns selbst könnt ihr euch
darauf einigen
dann würde ich euch bitten einen schritt
vorzugehen das ist zwar so dass wir mal
so abchecken wo wir hinkommen so und
jetzt merkt euch bitte wo er steht und
steckt mal die köpfe zusammen bin
gespannt was dabei rauskommt altes leben
stigmatisiert wird
da kommst du gar nicht mehr einfach nur
das rauszuschlagen weiß das gesetz
überhaupt bevor sie selber aber
natürlich habe er jetzt auch die
gelegenheit was ist der kompromiss zu
sagen wir mal eine these vielleicht ein
appell bitte die ihr formulieren könnte
sich alle grün wie gelb einigen können
bin gespannt auch etwas eingefallen ist
gerade bei diesem schwierigen thema
keine ahnung
es ist schwierig habt ihr irgendwas habt
ihr uns schwierig ich bin gegen konsens
auch voll okay der große streit das ist
doch voll okay also ich frage jetzt
gruppe geld habt ihr ein
kompromissvorschlag ja also um einen
kompromissvorschlag zu mal muss man eine
gemeinsame weise ist auf dem begriff
cloud kann man nicht verzichten
geht es bei euch drüben gibt es da
irgendwas wo er sagt mensch damit
kriegen wir sie die frauen werden
[Gelächter]
natürlich kriegt ihr uns mit forderungen
nach frühzeitiger integration danach ein
gesamtüberblick zu behalten und sachlich
zu bleiben es ist da gehen wir natürlich
mit klar also früher hilfe statt später
hätte ich über spitze ein bisschen um
einen punkt zu machen lieber nicht die
hundertschaft zu ali schicken und das
geld investieren denn einen
sozialarbeiter einmal klopfen ist
einfach klopfen
also ich fasse zusammen und da anders
weniger racial profiling und mehr der
spur des geldes folgen weniger racial
profiling und mehr der spur des geldes
folgen könnt ihr dem volk also sagen
wenn ihr geht sagen die wir wie sich
sogar vielleicht ja klage ich damit und
ich rede aber auch darüber wer welche
kriminellen taten begeht und wie sich
das entwickelt und wenn eben heute
gesagt wird das sind die araber dann
weil da heute im blick darauf geworfen
wird und einmal deshalb es ist auf alle
fälle eine politische entscheidungen wer
verfolgt wird wer gerade verfolgt wird
weil die ressourcen nicht da sind alle
zu verfolgen ja und jetzt ist es gerade
gewollt dass es die araber sein sollen
und wo ich auch mitgehen würde oder was
auf meine forderung wäre auch wenn es
vielleicht überrascht dass man die
polizei und die strafe ist einfach viel
viel besser ausstattet so auch der
kompromissvorschlag der kunden schritt
nach vorn
also nicht nur menschen besser technik
sondern auch intellektuell jungs mal
sozusagen nicht nur technik sondern auch
intellektuell chance ich weiß diese
diskussion ist wahnsinnig anstrengend
und sehr komplex ich bilde mir trotzdem
ein dass man eine gewisse sympathie für
verschiedene positionen hier entwickeln
konnte
wir werden am ende hier niemanden dem
kompromiss feld haben ehrlicherweise
finde ich es nicht total überraschend
bei dieser diskussion
ich danke euch sehr dass ihr trotzdem
teilgenommen hat und euch immerhin auch
ein bisschen bewegt hat vielen dank
die verdienen bekommen hast meine dass
also schnell dass er prophezeit safe
unterbezahlt ich hoffe dass jetzt alles
beim alten
das tut immer noch dahinter stehe ist
obwohl er die ganze zeit sagst du hast
recht du brauchst mehr geld kommt gibt
hier noch eine halben schritt hobbys
bleibt ich bin ich bin sie für mich wohl
du fühlst dich dann alles klar super
herzlichen dank euch allen 13 fragen
wann das danke an das wirklich 13 fragen
ich glaube das erste bei dieser thematik
ist wirklich auch das schweigen zu
brechen ich glaube wir dürfen nicht
unterschätzen wie tabuisiertes thema ist
auch aus angst davor fehler zu machen
ist es auch ein vermintes feld ist es
gibt viele verletzungen schmerzen auch
auf beiden seiten und ich glaube die
kommunikation darüber ist ein erster
wichtiger schritt und so habe ich diese
diskussion heute auch verstanden er
ich finde es sehr gut dass überhaupt
darüber geredet wird ja ich finde es
auch immer gut konfrontativ zu reden was
ich mitnehme ich freue mich über jeden
der sich ernsthaft damit beschäftigt das
gefühl hat dich oder den eindruck hatte
ich bei dir ganz toll und der da auch
mit fakten argumentieren kann und vor
allem auch damit mit berichten von
jugendlichen betroffenen usw
das nehme ich auf alle fälle mit also
ich hab heute definitiv von ihm gelernt
dass ja also beziehungsweise mein
bewusstsein hat sich einfach mal ein
bisschen gestärkt dieser blick auf diese
ganzen statistiken ja also du hast es
vorhin sehr bildlich beschrieben
und das ist schon so er da müssen wir
uns auch hinterfragen was es so in den
medien und so was wird denn da publik
gemacht welche schlagzeile
kommt dann wieder an die zeitung ist das
vielleicht wirklich so oder hinterfragen
wir uns vielleicht ein bisschen und
informieren und selbst ein bisschen über
das thema bevor wir das so
stigmatisieren
ich bin in meiner arbeit als
reisejournalist ja auf kritische
perspektiven auch innerhalb der behörden
angewiesen das heißt wenn du was zu
berichten heißt quellenschutz 100
prozent ich fand es natürlich immer auch
interessant auch noch meine anderen
seite zu hören um zu verstehen was
eigentlich vielleicht ein defizit ist
und ich glaube dass wir noch mehr über
kritisches lesen von informationen reden
müssen
sowohl in den medien aber auch von den
behörden ausgehen
ja das war ja heute keine klassische
procontra diskussion aber ich glaube es
ist doch gelungen empathie zu erzeugen
für die einzelnen argumente sowohl von
ali als auch mohamed ria oder dorothea
und den anderen das sind ja alles
legitime positionen in dieser debatte
und wenn ihr ein bisschen mehr
verständnis gewonnen habt dann würde ich
mich freuen ja wer hat euch überzeugt
bei wem habt ihr vielleicht sogar eure
meinung komplett geändert schreibt gerne
in die kommentare und wenn euch 13
fragen gefällt hier könnt ihr unseren
kanal abonnieren hier oben gibt es eine
weitere folge 13 fragen und hier findet
ihr ein weiteres video zum thema